i don't think you could fit two glocks
in your pockets that was a slim cut
khaki there was no way i was getting two
blocks
well hey there i'm ryan reynolds hi i'm
jody coma hi there i'm sean levy and
we're going to be breaking down the
scene from our new film free guy
[Music]
wow
you should definitely go
this is inside a stash house uh and it's
a scene it's kind of an action scene
right jody i feel like you trained for
quite a while to get this choreography
down yeah definitely i mean this is
definitely the most i've ever worked
with a with a stunt department which was
so insightful and just getting to see
how meticulously they work this was over
a few days wasn't it did we shoot this
over like two or three days this scene
took us 61 days yeah it wasn't quite
like i messed up a couple i want to say
it was four or five and uh and it's it's
a scene that kind of in a way it
encapsulates a lot of what we tried to
do in the movie in general which is a
real mixture of action
and comedy and uh
characters that you root for
[Music]
oh my god that was not me that was my
incredible stunt double hailey right
like i am not taking credit for that and
she was phenomenal i mean i did as much
as i possibly possibly could and that
was kind of like really important to me
to kind of throw myself into that but
that that was was hayley um i can't lie
i can't lie
well
jody did a big jump then it's haley
doing the flip and then jody was kind of
straddling ryan on the
fake motorcycle on them and basically it
was like three two one trump so jody
sold the landing i mean you stuck that
landing jump
thank you sean
is that a glock in your pocket no what
it's two glocks
[Music]
i remember this glock in your pocket
this was an example where there was a
version of this joke in the script and
then i think ryan rewrote it and then i
rewrote ryan and then ryan rewrote me
and it evolved into this two glocks and
uh but as ryan and jody can tell you
there was no part of the scene that i
personally enjoyed more every take when
jody reaches to grab the gun and ryan
does this gun go
kind of
that's his reaction it's so silly it's
so little boy dumb and it made me laugh
every single day
this is my first film and everything
about it was so overwhelming and
spectacular and i remember coming to
that and thinking god how are we gonna
do it and we were in the stash house and
there was a kind of stationary motorbike
which was on like a device that that
spinned around once we were on it
which is just so crazy because you know
when you watch it on on the film it
looks
it looks so cool and then i've seen it
like bts that was on it and it's it
looks like it's going super slow
and it's like development does it look
kind of like almost like a lame child's
ride
yeah
that's what it looks like
um so it's incredible seeing that you
know once it's all edited together and
in its kind of final form
yeah so generally i try
and we try we approach
most scenes i don't want to storyboard
it i don't want to plan for it i have a
sense of where i want the actors but i
want it to feel free and organic but if
there's stunts or visual effects i want
it rigorously prepared and so i
storyboarded uh those shots and i just
remember there felt i just wanted
molotov girl to feel like an instant
classic heroine and uh and just her
control with those guns on the bike
basically guy is just trying to look
around her and drive straight but those
slow motion shots
sometimes you just kind of
imagine well what would i always try to
think what would i want it to look like
if i were in the audience and those were
the images that came to me i wanted kind
of iconic clean frames that looked like
two heroes
who the world didn't even know were
heroes yet
[Music]
what i love about this scene is that it
really is a showcase for jody and her
character molotov girl and her skills i
just love that guy sort of sits back and
watches like he's sitting front row with
popcorn in his hand uh watching the love
of his life just kick absolute ass just
turning every one of these bad guys into
a fine
curd cottage cheese like ass pudding and
it was so much fun to watch and then we
sort of set this whole thing to this
mamas and the papa's uh song make your
own kind of music oh it's so good
that's what's underneath
you know it also that that reminds me
that was not in the script and there was
no plan to use that song or to slow down
time and have guy
watch molotov girl adoringly but as we
were shooting it ryan said to jody and i
hey listen to this song is this weird
should we like have me just watch you in
a trance and he played the song and it
was weird but it was weird good weird in
the way that many of ryan reynolds
musical instincts are good and also
inspired and also another example of how
we had a really good script that we
worked really hard on but then every day
we just kind of tried to stay nimble
enough that we could listen to new ideas
and be surprised by stuff that the movie
kind of revealed
[Music]
[Music]
the vast majority of the movie was done
practically um and not just the sets
but
almost every explosion missile hit
flamethrower zipline
bombs going that was all real so i i do
have to kind of give a huge shout out to
the stunt and effects department because
all those background jokes where mayhem
is happening that was really happening
and these actors and rel had to play it
completely straight and non-reactive
this particular set was built it was
uh inspired partly by a library at my
alma mater yale there's a library called
the beineckey rare book library and the
walls are these slabs of very thin
marble and
early on i said to my production
designer let's have this be inspired by
nikki library yale and uh we built it
and uh it the whole set was there all
the vehicles are there and to your point
earlier i'm remembering that those were
like i don't know
half a million dollar sports car and
each one came with its owner so that was
my favorite part i remember that with
the onus
yeah that was amazing so like we're
there trying to make a movie and there's
like all these rich middle-aged men
who own these sports cars they cost an
insane amount of money and we're
shooting like fighting and flips and god
help us if something were to have
touched the car and damage it in front
of its owner who was for some reason
standing by me at the camera going up be
careful my maserati is not going to
handle gunfire well i think all the cars
had names like you know grace and phil
my my testerosa and yeah it was just my
testimony i'm still stuck on the fact
that your your alma mater has the
library filled with rare books i think
that's amazing
i mean like
it is a it is a very fancy school my
alma mater has a library filled with old
episodes of who's the boss
you know congratulations
you win
[Music]
mondays am i right joe you said it guy
check out free guy available to watch
right now i'm not as good as ryan at
this
you